[Music]
on this saturday night
record cases in the hardest hit
provinces
why isn't there more enforcement to stop
the surge
most people actually don't want to live
in a police state
and the burden on hospitals trying to
help clovid19 patients
a global news exclusive what went on
inside an
ontario care home where the virus killed
17 people
and people is not taking it seriously
ethiopia on the verge of civil war and
accusations of ethnic targeting plus
the presidential pet and its importance
to the white house
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us there has been an alarming surge of
covet 19 cases
across canada and today is no exception
alberta recorded more than a thousand
new cases
a single day record saskatchewan just
shattered its single day record
with 308 new cases ontario also broke a
record
it logged more than 1500 new cases
and quebec reported more than 1400 new
infections
another record-breaking single day
increase
as we hear about these records broken on
a near daily basis
there are calls for authorities to do
more to stop the spread of coven 19.
provincial governments are hesitant to
use lockdown measures
this time around so what's the answer as
mike delay reports there's a fine line
between
pleading and policing sir i understand
you're here for peaceful protest
second world war same propaganda there
doesn't appear to be a middle ground
here
the protesters arguing for freedom are
steadfast in their beliefs
it's about you know a government that's
controlling the people with
a little bit of oppression a little bit
of tyranny and then there's the
anti-anti-massacres like brad bradford
who's trying to protect family members
who are considered high risk of getting
covet 19.
wearing a mask is a minor inconvenience
for any of us i mean
it's like putting a hat on and caught in
the middle of it all
is an overwhelmed health care system and
those tasked with enforcing the law
the problem is that the rules vary so
much across the country
nobody is entirely sure what's
enforceable and that's as true in
toronto
we have never nor will we ever take
enforcement action related to
recommendations
as it is in calgary this is not the time
that we should have to
enforce anything what he means is that
after eight months living in a pandemic
and with new case numbers surging to
record highs canadians should know
better
except we saw on halloween that that
isn't always the case
and with the southeast asian festival
diwali happening this weekend
authorities are once again opting for
education over enforcement i know people
want to come together to celebrate their
faith especially now at
diwali time and to celebrate weddings
and other milestones
but i'm asking you as the mayor as
directly as i can
to stay home as much as possible right
now bioethicist carrie bowman says
that's the right way to go for now one
of the problems with enforcement
is you know most people actually don't
want to live in a police state
and you know with the pandemic we're
really extending
the role of the authorities a great deal
but if gatherings like this turn into
super spreader events
he says a firmer approach may be
warranted
microlight global news toronto there are
signs the atlantic bubble
could be bursting new cases are popping
up in several provinces
there were two cases reported today in
newfoundland and labrador
both are travel related nova scotia
recorded six new cases
so did new brunswick for the first time
in a week manitoba recorded
under 300 new cases today but 15 more
people have died of coven 19 in that
province
it's the largest jump in fatalities
reported on a single day
they include 11 residents from a
long-term care home
in winnipeg seniors in long-term
care and retirement homes make up over
80 percent of canada's kova 19 deaths
there are now more than 350 homes with
active outbreaks in canada and it's
especially frustrating for those who
were on the front lines
of the first wave tonight in a global
news exclusive
far nasser reports on what went on
inside an ontario care home
that was hit hard provide 19 was an
unprecedented crisis but to those who
worked in the industry
the warning signs were there in this
field you're always short
but we work with what we have
maggie gittins worked as a psw at mark
haven home for seniors near toronto for
30 years
until she caught the virus in late march
did you give care to that first patient
was my assignment i thought my goodness
we should be wearing everything
and she should be maybe in in hospital
i had on this stuff but you're wearing
this
this was it this kind of a mask or was
it n95 it was this kind of a mask
this yes it wasn't a medical grade mask
this
this as a result of that
i almost lost my life when the first
mark haven resident tested positive on
march 20th
mark haven executive director mike
bakewell sent an email to the family
members of residents
reassuring them mark haven was working
closely with health authorities
and following correct protocols but
internal email exchanges show a lack of
cooperation between the home and health
authorities
and failing protocols one minute you're
told you're not supposed to do this one
minute you're told you
do this you know so you don't know
which way you're going in a little more
than two months
17 of mark haven's 96 residents were
dead markhaven is one of many
long-term care homes named in class
action lawsuits
we requested an on-camera interview with
mark haven but the executive director
declined on the advice of lawyers
he claimed they strictly followed public
health guidelines
and praised the efforts of staff during
the outbreak
maggie gitton spent weeks in hospital in
intensive care
unconscious six months later she's still
traumatized
it's scary for me you know to go outside
to go anywhere to go
in the store to go somewhere where you
have people
it's the hardest thing to do now
especially
with the second wave
and people is not taking it seriously
fara nasser
global news toronto and you can check
out the extended version of that story
tonight on the new reality with donna
friesen
starting at 7 p.m right here on global
as you heard earlier a thousand new
cases in alberta and restrictions are in
place but not everyone feels the new
rules go far enough
calgary's mayor is calling for tougher
measures nahanenshi is voicing those
concerns on the west block
with mercedes stevenson mercedes
robin calgary's mayor naheed nenshi says
people need to shake off their covet
fatigue
and realize that things will get out of
control very quickly
unless drastic action is taken i feel a
bit like chicken little
for the last several weeks saying things
are really bad we're getting close to
overwhelming our health care system and
people go
but we're only at 62 utilization of icu
beds we've got tons of room
not realizing that exponential growth
means that
to go from 50 to 100 is just one step
you can do that in a week given that
we're doubling every week here now
so i'm glad that people are finally
seeing how important this
is says many albertans feel the
restrictions announced this week were
quote
a bit random pointing out the casinos
remained open but
kids sports were shut down there's a
huge backlash this week after the
premier made his announcement
from parents saying why in the world are
you stopping my kids sports which is
helping them keep them sane helping them
have a bit of normalcy in their lives
where there's very little evidence of
spread in kids sports
now we don't actually know if that's
true because two-thirds of cases we
don't know where they came from
but if the premier had said listen we
need to keep the schools open
and we're seeing spread in schools so
that what we need to do is
restrict our kids activities outside of
school so we can get the virus out of
the schools and keep the schools open
i think people would have gone okay that
makes sense nancy says
identifying where the community spread
is happening and a more targeted
approach to restrictions will help get
the second wave
under control robin mercedes stevenson
in ottawa thanks mercedes
for more on what nenshi thinks about the
handling of this pandemic tune into the
west block tomorrow
right here on global the u.s has broken
another record for new coven 19 cases in
a 24-hour period
more than 180 000 people tested positive
for the virus and more than 1400
died nearly every state is seeing a
spike in cases prompting governments
to bring in new restrictions and as
jennifer johnson explains
americans are being warned to stay put
this holiday season
from north dakota to texas california to
massachusetts
new cases of covet 19 are sweeping
across america
governors even republicans are ordering
stringent new measures to get the virus
under control
partially locking down their states and
issuing mass mandates
our state is caught in the middle of a
skyrocketing national
covet 19 storm north dakota is not alone
my executive order idaho is deploying
national guard soldiers to help
overwhelmed hospitals decontaminate and
test patients
new york city new mexico oregon and many
others are clamping down on indoor
activities
i'm announcing a two-week freeze
for the entire state colorado has
declared the situation a level one
emergency
its highest california is among several
states
issuing travel advisories if i have
three children i have five grandchildren
and normally we do get together either
at thanksgiving or christmas but
not this year because of the covid
november is on track to be the worst
month americans have seen
but experts warn the surge will likely
peak in january
we're going to see by far the darkest
days of this pandemic
between now and next spring when vaccine
becomes available
hospitals in at least 14 states have or
are close to running out of room
we're on what we call critical bed
status that means
we have fewer than about five general
medical beds
available in many states lines to get
tested are stretching for blocks
all of our appointments have been
filling up
to the point now that we're going to be
adding another half day of testing
starting next week many experts are
telling americans to put a stop to small
indoor parties and game nights
while few health officials are
advocating for a nationwide lockdown
millions of businesses are getting hit
again the restaurant industry as we know
it
is dead this latest surge of the virus
is costing more people their lives
and their livelihoods jennifer johnson
global news
washington supporters of donald trump
have taken to the streets of washington
[Applause]
tens of thousands marched along
pennsylvania avenue
many were carrying flags and signs
backing the outgoing president
trump delighted his supporters by
driving through the rally on his way to
the virginia golf club
he's still refusing to concede the
election to democrat joe biden
on friday judges in the swing states of
arizona michigan and pennsylvania
all dismiss court challenges aimed at
overturning the election results
the rcmp have laid more charges related
to violence against
indigenous lobster fishers in nova
scotia 74 year old ivan tibo is facing
two counts of assault
in connection with a standoff at a
lobster compound last month
about 200 non-indigenous commercial
fishers swarmed this site
as tensions flared over the migma
livelihood fishery
it was one of two facilities targeted
that day the rcmp say the investigation
is ongoing tebow will appear in
provincial court
in february coming up the calls for the
world to investigate war crimes in
ethiopia
and typhoon vancouver sets its sights on
vietnam
global national is back in two minutes
in the philippines whole villages remain
underwater
three days after a typhoon slammed the
country at least 53 people have been
killed
the coast guard and disaster agencies
are scrambling to rescue thousands
trapped by fast-flowing floodwaters
vietnam is expected to be hit tonight
with heavy rains and winds up to 150
kilometers per hour
that country is preparing an evacuation
plan for 460
000 people the un
says ethiopia is a country on the verge
of a civil war and the ongoing conflict
has forced more people to flee to nearby
sudan
hundreds of people arrived in this small
border town today
this camp is meant to house 300 refugees
but it's now home to eight thousand
authorities are ramping up assistance
but the number of new arrivals is
outpacing capacity
the united nations is preparing for up
to a hundred thousand people to flee
ethiopia in the coming days and weeks
earlier this month fighting began
between government troops and forces
loyal
to insurgent leaders in the tigray
region
hundreds of people have been killed and
more than seventeen thousand
others have fled ethnic armenians in the
disputed region of nagorno-karabakh
are packing up their homes as a bitter
conflict with azerbaijan
comes to an end they're leaving nothing
behind
not even the houses
villagers set their homes on fire so
they won't be occupied by azerbaijanis
earlier this week russia brokered an
agreement that ended six weeks of heavy
fighting between armenia and azerbaijan
the deal will see control of several
areas of nagorno-karabakh
handed over to azerbaijan the entire
region
is legally recognized as part of
azerbaijan but
is largely populated by ethnic armenians
russia has deployed peacekeepers to
ensure this
ceasefire holds a fire has ripped
through romanian
hospital treating people with coven 19.
at least 10 people are reported dead and
seven
others critically injured a doctor tried
to save patients from the flames but he
suffered second-degree burns over 80
percent of his body the fire broke out
in the intensive care ward of the
hospital
which is located about 350 kilometers
north of the country's capital
romania's health minister says it likely
started as the result of a short circuit
the country has recorded more than 353
000 cases of kova 19 since the start of
the pandemic
still had the temporary tents pitched as
a lasting protection
for health care workers
you're watching global national
as cobit 19 cases surge across the
country
the safety of health care workers is a
critical concern
many hospitals are being stretched to
their limits and they need
all hands on deck now a made in canada
device could reduce the risk to those
working on the front lines while saving
lives
su lingo reports shortly after
covid19 cases hit edmonton emergency
room physician mark curiel was inserting
a tube in a patient's windpipe
when he realized how unprotected he was
my mask didn't fit because i didn't
shave that day
so i'm wearing my mask and i'm feeling
air leaking in the sides and the whole
time i'm thinking
what am i going to be bringing home to
my family he reached out to a friend
mechanical engineer chris tariff to
brainstorm a solution they came up
with this an aerosol containment tent
it uses suction and a hepa filter to
remove
any covid infected droplets from the air
really the concept is build a portable
negative pressure area over a patient's
head
and we built it aerosol generating
procedures such as intubation
bipap and ventilation can spray
particles up to 10 meters away
which can stay infectious for up to
three hours
dr curiel says the pandemic has changed
how they do things in hospitals
i have not used bypass since kobit
started and this is a technique that
would
get people better faster and instead of
sending them to the icu
we can send them to the regular medicine
floor this tent would allow
airway procedures to be done safely
anywhere
it's portable so whether it's a hotel or
whether it's a gymnasium or
something if we needed to go and create
a temporary
field hospital these could be basically
brought out and portable enough to use
for any bed in the facility
dr curiel says his er has been short
staffed since kovid started
reducing exposure means fewer healthcare
workers isolating
and fewer disruptions to the system
whether they have a broken leg or a
heart attack
patients will feel the impact of
procedure delays
anything that can increase efficiency
will help everyone
so our goal is not only let's protect
the staff but let's protect the whole
health care system
and and allow these people who are
saving lives to stay at work and keep
doing what
they've been trained to do lingo global
news
trump let the dogs out biden's gonna
bring them back
up next all paws on deck in the white
house
birthday wishes are pouring in for
prince charles who turns
72 today the royal family took to social
media posting two pictures of the queen
with her son to mark the occasion
celebrations in london are obviously
suspended because of covet 19.
the prince was diagnosed with the virus
in march now recovered
the next in line to the throne penned a
birthday article for country life
magazine
addressing the pandemic and climate
change
at least one tradition isn't taking a
back seat in this pandemic
the presidential pooch dogs have joined
every u.s leader in the white house
except
donald trump president-elect joe biden
has two german shepherds
and when his family moves into 1600
pennsylvania avenue
there will be a furry first michael
couture explains
much has been made of the historic
nature of the u.s election
and there's a furry footnote that is
giving some dog lovers a reason to bark
for the first time in four years paws
will be walking the halls of the white
house
with the arrival of president-elect joe
biden's german shepherds
champ and major what makes this pup
particular is that he's the first
first dog that's a rescue adopted two
years ago by
then former vice president biden from
the delaware humane association
this litter of puppies had had come from
a dire situation and we had all really
uh become attached to them so it was a
really really exciting day
obviously because president-elect joe
biden was there
there was no security and very little
fanfare when biden picked up his
pooch but workers hope major's newfound
fame
will reframe how people see shelter
animals what we really hope
is that other people will be inspired by
majors rags to riches story
the importance of adoption is so so real
there's nothing more rewarding than
adopting an animal from an animal
shelter
it's long been the practice for
presidents to have pets in the white
house
president calvin coolidge had colleagues
the clintons had a cat named
sox and william howard taft had a pet
cow named pauline
historically when a first family has a
furry friend
there's a copycat effect pun intended
with
others around the world rushing to get
similar breeds
and that has humane societies in canada
bracing for an
even bigger influx of adoptive families
because of kova 19 and the pandemic and
people being home
during this time adoptions have soared
but you know now with knowing that
the the new president of the united
states has an adopted dog
that's really maybe just going to boost
things a little bit more and given the
current state of american politics
maybe it is time for a rescue dog in the
white
house mike lacreter global news ottawa
and that is global national for this
saturday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is the quaint and
colorful
kitty vide village in st john's
newfoundland and labrador
the popular spot is one of the oldest
fishing villages in north america
we'd love to see your part of canada so
email your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]